i believe that good pitching beats good
hitting this is what's going to be the
case for brady i like him he's digging
in he's towing him
throwing the slab and tim right side has
himself a base hit past a diving dozier
anderson has been on five of six times
he's come to the plate in this series
yesterday edwin encarnacion crushed one
to left field
moving up the list of home run hitters
in major league baseball 421 now gloria
pats the glove one ball
two strikes edwin hits it in the ears
center field
olivares is there to make the catch tim
tags he's on his way home yowan to third
and the sox strike first
sac fly and carnazzi own one nothing and
the sox have two on nobody out
and mazzara is down on strikes and
that's brady's first tonight
nick had a base hit for a run batted in
the last time he looked at singer
two and two on the ground up the middle
into center base hit eloy around
third and olivares forgot the ball the
sox get another run
and that moves mccann to third two
nothing socks here in the second inning
the royals have
committed 24 errors this year half of
those have come against the white sox
they have allowed 19 unearned runs
and nine of those have come against the
white sox
and he takes a fastball for a strike so
he wasn't expecting that
down in the count oh and two and singer
gets another big strikeout with a runner
in scoring position
dane dunning on for his third start the
era is very good last time out he could
hardly be any better than that 14
strikeouts and nine in the third only
two walks
he's got absolute pinpoint control
swinging a foul tip held by mccann
that's strike three
first strikeout for dunning one away
here in the second it's one
two nothing that is the white sox had
the lead here in the second inning
come on monty get a little boost little
confidence booster here
and there's a base hit into right field
so mondeep
drives in a run and he puts an end to an
0 for 22
which was the longest current drought in
the major leagues
oh that was nice there you go monday
02. tipped into the glove strength three
royals get one back
another tight one between the socks and
kansas city
there's a called third strike and
carnacion is not so sure and that is
brady's third strikeout
and another called third strike one ball
one strike
nick into center field base hit again
and mazara makes the turn for third nick
madrigal
two for two the royals are gonna be real
sick of him so back to the top of the
order for tim anderson fluke to right
and there is merrifield his throw coming
home azara
beats it and a sac fly for ta driving in
the third run
tonight look we talked before the ball
game that's the one thing you give away
if you put mary field in right field he
is a second baseman
and here comes alex back to the middle
and anderson will come to the plate
and franco is safe so anderson
recognized
that that was a one-out play
and figured he'd try and get that out at
home plate all right let's see what
monday does here he
snapped an o for 22 in his last at-bat
and monteci got a hittable pitch on oh
and two and he's going to drive in alex
gordon for a second time tonight
this one will tie the game olivares goes
to third and alberto mondesi is two for
two with two rbis
so ready to lead off and abreu is down
on strikes
and that is singer's fifth
line into center field and carnacion
will make the turn
he will go to third olivarez throws that
way jimenez stops it first
and there's runners at the corners with
two down and it's another
single for the white sox two out for
james mccann
who takes inside off the glove of
valoria
and edwin scores four three sox retaking
the lead
and now at loy he's into third base
broncos says
whoa here and the sox will take a 4-3
advantage
one ball two strikes to solaire
swinging a miss strike three so lair is
not going to go through with the charade
of running to first base
call the cartoonists two down he just
couldn't wait for a slider blown away to
swing at and take a seat
and dane has made some very good pitches
this inning this
is so far a great bounce back in him for
him anderson with a single a strikeout
and a sacrifice flight
line drive right field his second hit
tonight
the way he has swung in the two games
he's seen singer i'm surprised matheny
left him in to face anderson
and so singer will depart he is down in
the score
so here is jesse hahn in a call to the
bullpen with two down
in the sixth two and one jose
in the air left center field and he does
it again
an alley ball from abreu once home
here comes moncada it is six three
sox and the hit streak goes to 18.
well pretty much you can just take it to
the bank that if there's a big hit to be
gotten
it's jose abreu who's gonna get it
one two breaking ball swatted to left
and a diving play not made gordon
couldn't haul it in
and roberts got himself first base and
here is eloy jimenez
in the air left center field long run
and it's down over the head of
olivares robert around third racing home
no throw coming there and an
rbi double eloy jimenez who continues to
swing it mighty well tonight
and it's 7-3 the closer seventh grade in
save situations this is one of those
he's got two on tying run in the on deck
circle he's got to win his way by
o'hearn
and ryan takes a walk and here comes
whit merrifield
representing the tying run swinging a
bit strike three it was a cutter
that sent him packing he has one for
four he also has his first
royals rbi tonight and olivares it's a
line drive
off of madrigal's glove that'll get
franco to the plate
it is 7-4 and ryan mcbroom is going to
get a chance to come up with two on and
two out
tapper out in front of the plate mccann
accurate for the final out and the sox
win
seven to four and are back in first
place after a slog tonight